yo soy cardiólogo
y voy a compartir con ustedes una
corazonada que tuve
hace ya cerca de 12 años un 31 de
diciembre a las 9 de la mañana
fuera de bogotá
súbitamente tuve una opresión en la
mandíbula
esa opresión de manera muy rápida se
trasladó a la boca del estómago al
epigastrio
y se acompañó de una sensación de
desasosiego de ansiedad ahí entendí de
alguna manera a mis pacientes sobre todo
las mujeres que decían es que no me
hallo y si efectivamente era esa
sensación de ansiedad en que uno no se
hallaba ni sentado ni acostado ni de pie
a los 5 minutos por otros síntomas
comprendí que lo que yo en ese momento
tenía era un infarto al corazón
y estaba cursando
un infarto
le dije a mi señora yolanda a mi esposa
me siento muy mal vámonos para la
clínica
fuimos para la clínica a los 10 minutos
estábamos en la clínica de iniciados los
síntomas a los 15 minutos de iniciados
los síntomas
pedí un electrocardiograma
y efectivamente el electrocardiograma se
comprobó que tenía un gran infarto en la
cara anterior del corazón por
obstrucción de la arteria coronaria
principal que irriga el corazón
sería muy claro los riesgos inminentes
de muerte
o el riesgo inminente de amor
y muy claro la posibilidad de un daño
grande del músculo cardíaco por el resto
de la vida
se hizo lo que se debía hacer
y adecuado intensivo
un anticoagulante muy potente que se
llama estreptoquinasa
es como una especie de rojo que
está para cañerías
efectivamente se destapó
y sentir los síntomas de la
desobstrucción de la arteria coronaria y
lo que vino después fue había una
ambulancia trasladado a bogotá en avión
ambulancia y la sorpresa mayor dos días
después cuando
durante la arteriografía coronaria
durante el cateterismo yo veo en la
pantalla unas arterias coronarias
supremamente feas
muy deterioradas
a partir de ese momento
la salud para mí se convirtió en mi
prioridad
hasta entonces yo consideraba que me
cuidaba
consideraba que tenía una vida sana
de hecho no tenía factores de riesgo muy
significativos
un poquito elevado el colesterol mucho
estrés
y sobre todo de ese estrés de emociones
negativas que llamo yo tóxicas o
destructivas que llaman algunos otros
esos fardos que uno no termina de
elaborar y los va arrastrando a lo largo
de la vida
pero nada de hipertensión y diabetes ni
nada de esas cosas
cuando yo nací la expectativa de vida en
colombia era un poco superior a los 50
años
en mi caso casi se cumple
me salvó
la tecnología los avances tecnológicos y
me ha mantenido el cuidado y
particularmente el amor de mi familia de
mi señora de mis hijos que han adoptado
los mismos hábitos de vida
hoy nacen en colombia 1750 bebés diarios
las niñas nacen con 82 con una
expectativa de vida de 82 años
y los niños con una expectativa de vida
de 76 años
y otras palabras vivirán hasta finales
de este siglo y muy posiblemente pasarán
al siguiente sitio
en el lapso de tiempo de entre
el momento en que yo nací y en el
momento en que están haciendo estos
niños hoy
estos bebés
la expectativa de vida ha crecido a una
tasa de 2.5 días por semana
si seguimos a este ritmo en colombia los
bebés que van a nacer el último día de
este ciclo
vivirán desde el siglo 21 hasta el siglo
las niñas nacerán con una expectativa de
vida de 110 años y los niños con una
expectativa de vida de 104 años
la pregunta que yo me hago es
que deben entender esos bebés por salud
que deben entender por prioridad en
salud
de alguna manera eso es lo que queremos
compartir con ustedes en esta mañana la
salud se volvió una prioridad para mí
el día que me dio el infarto
afortunadamente se intervino a tiempo
y eso llevó un par de díaz ductos
porque fue esos adelantos técnicos que
llevaron a una cirugía de corazón
abierto y todas las arterias coronarias
quedaron con puentes
envejecemos
desde que nacemos
de que nacemos empieza un proceso lento
pero sostenido
de un
recambio celular y todos los días nacen
células y númer en celdas
es algo autónomo ni lo percibimos
desde pequeños nos enseñaron
muchos de los que estamos acá lo
recordarán en los colegios
los seres vivos
nacen crecen se reproducen y mueren
lo tenemos claro
sin embargo
lo dejamos a un lado lo tratamos de
olvidar
el envejecimiento como la muerte es algo
que le sucede a otros
bs
mis abuelos y envejecieron murieron
envejecen mis padres mis tíos los
vecinos
inclusive acepto que envejecen mis
hermanos
pero yo
yo envejezco
mis abuelas y la forma como
embellecieron ellas
me enseñaron
como reafirmaron
y luego nos dicen
que el proceso de envejecimiento es es
un proceso fisiológico fisiopatológico
si se quiere
pero para mí
a partir de ellas la vejez es una
actitud de la vida
la forma como nos paramos ante ese
proceso natural de envejecimiento
como lo enfrentamos
esa es una realidad y por eso uno
encuentra tantos jóvenes viejos
y tantos viejos jóvenes
es la actitud es la manera cómo
enfrentamos ese que quizás es nuestro
mayor reto una realidad para la cual
nacimos
de otra parte
en el sector salud a nivel nacional y
mundial permanecemos en una constante
discusión sobre qué es salud
entonces algunos dicen que la salud o se
reafirman a la definición de la
organización mundial de la salud desde
hace 1948
que dice que la salud es el completo y
subrayo la palabra completo bienestar
físico
mental
y social del individuo y no solamente la
ausencia de enfermedad
para muchos entre los que me encuentro
esa es una visión utópica
se completo bienestar en esos tres
aspectos pues si se logra son instantes
y ha venido
una nueva tendencia más fuerte cada vez
con la cual yo me encuentro bastante
identificado
que nos dice que la salud es la
capacidad de individuos y comunidades de
gestionar adecuadamente los retos
físicos
mentales y sociales que la vida no se
enfrenta
parecería eso mucho más real
y si nosotros unimos las dos reflexiones
por una parte envejecemos todos los días
y esa es una realidad
una realidad repito y no perceptible
durante mucho tiempo hasta que nos
paramos en un espejo
y uno dice mira con este tipo quién es
i
esa realidad la unimos con la definición
de salud uno podría decir que la vida no
es otra cosa que buscar un
envejecimiento sano
buscar un envejecimiento con bienestar
y ese es el reto que todos tenemos
ah
pero entonces uno se pregunta en ese
marco de cosas
cuáles son
digamos los retos o los sub retos que es
de grande que uno debería digamos aunque
uno está enfrentando
el primero conservar la salud
preservarla
preservarla lo más que se pueda
pero la realidad es que vivimos en la
industria de la enfermedad
cuando uno le pregunta a las personas
sobre la salud lo primero en que piensan
es en una enfermedad
a uno le pasa lo mismo
de hecho la salud se convirtió en una
prioridad para mí el día que me perdí
en segundo lugar el cuidado y la
protección económica para la vejez y
esto no es menor
solamente el 23 por ciento 23 de cada
100 personas mayores de 60 años en
colombia hoy
tiene una pensión
y no tenemos una cultura de ahorro
por el contrario muchas veces gastamos
más del
nos dejamos llevar por esa tendencia
y el tercer reto que hace parte de ese
envejecimiento sano que mencionó
tiene que ver con el cuidado al final de
la vida
con aceptar que somos finitos
aceptar que nacimos para morir
y ese es el destino común que tenemos
todos quizás lo más democrático que
tenemos los seres humanos si se quiere
de esa manera
pero el cuidado en esa etapa está en
manos
de las mujeres está centrado en un
cuidado a partir de las mujeres que a su
vez cuidan personas que son mayores y a
su vez pide cuidan personas mayores y
personas con discapacidad
no hay un sistema nacional de cuidado en
colombia
pero quizás el énfasis mayor que yo
quisiera en esta reflexión
dejar es
hoy morimos más limpios
pero solos
norbert es díaz un sociólogo
el 70% de los seres humanos cuando se
les pregunta
queremos morir en nuestra casa
de nuestros seres queridos
pero la realidad es que medicalizados la
muerte
y hoy el 70 por ciento de las personas
mueren alejados de su hogar
muy limpios seguramente pero en un
escenario
hospitalario
por no a ellos
esos son los retos que a mi modo de ver
enfrentamos
en ese proceso de envejecimiento sano al
cual nos enfrentamos todos los seres
humanos sí
reconocemos que la vida es un proceso
lento de un envejecimiento que debe ser
sano
y comprendemos que el 90% de la salud de
un individuo
no depende de la organización de
servicios de salud
y depende fundamentalmente de sus
hábitos de vida del medio ambiente que
lo rodea
y de algo que todavía no hemos terminado
y apenas está empezando a explorar que
es nuestra genética
pero que la organización de servicios de
salud impacta la salud de un individuo
solamente en un 10%
entonces qué debemos hacer
yo diría que lo que debemos hacer es
desmedicalizar la sal
y empezar por ahí
tienes de ustedes tienen hijos menores
de edad por favor levanten la mano
nietos o sobrinos nietos
yo me encuentro entre los tres
que deben aprender ellos
qué es lo que deberían ellos comprender
y entender esos bebés que van a nacer
esos que ya nacieron y que hoy tienen
esas edades cuáles son las capacidades
que ellos deben desarrollar
yo creo que para eso la responsabilidad
es de todos
el estado tendrá que hacer lo que debe
hacer
pero cada uno de nosotros debe atender
este tema
con suficiencia y con adecuado enfoque
a mí me parece que podríamos proponer el
establecimiento
de un seguro cultural
el tema no es solamente la prevención y
la promoción claro esas son importantes
y son parte de la organización de los
servicios de salud y necesitamos
estimular las más sin duda
pero nosotros como seres humanos como
ciudadanos como padres abuelos tíos
abuelos de esos bebés de hoy de esos
futuros bebés de mañana
es lo que debemos hacer
esos bebés deberían nacer en un
escenario en el cual ese seguro social
cultural existiera
un sol duro
que no tiene por qué tener afiliación
que no requiere un nuevo pago de una
cotización
es un seguro al cual deberían estar
titulados simplemente por nacer en
nuestra sociedad
y debería buscarse que ese seguro
estuviera orientado al cuidado integral
en esos tres aspectos que hablamos
el cuidado de la salud y deberíamos
aprender y enseñar que la salud es el
activo más preciado que tenemos en la
vida
es la inversión fundamental
pero a veces la damos por garantía
o la mayoría de las veces
lo otro que deberían aprender esos bebés
es que la salud está en nuestra
cotidianidad
en nuestro día a día
la salud está en la calidad del sueño
que tenemos
en lo que comemos en lo que bebemos en
lo que consumimos
en la actividad física que realizamos y
no nos tenemos que convertir en atletas
de alto rendimiento para poderlo hacer
la salud está en nuestra vida sexual
sana
está en nuestra inteligencia emocional y
en la capacidad que tengamos de resolver
adecuadamente nuestras diferencias y
nuestros conflictos
está en la inteligencia que tengamos
para comprender que somos seres
vulnerables y que tenemos un destino
común
todos vamos para el mismo rumbo
y que está en esa capacidad que tengamos
de manejar adecuadamente nuestro entorno
ese sería un primer punto
el cuidado y la preservación de la salud
desde esa perspectiva
pero uno que no es menor
es prever económicamente nuestra vejez
y tener tranquilidad para esa etapa de
la vida
claro
habrá que cotizar a las pensiones y el
estado colombiano en particular tendrá
que hacer
las reformas necesarias para que de
verdad el sistema pensional colombiano
a universal
y solidario y sea verdaderamente
efectivo y eficiente
pero por el otro lado desde el punto de
vista individual
lo que deberíamos es fijarnos una meta
como sociedad al menos el ahorro de un
10 por ciento de nuestros ingresos
no importa el monto de los ingresos
pero que estableciéramos un monto mínimo
como una meta social
por ese aspecto de la protección al
final de la vejez al final de la vida
o para la vejez pero también porque es
una manera de que nuestra sociedad
crezca económicamente
y en la medida en que nuestra sociedad
crece económicamente va a haber mayor
bienestar y por tal habrá más salud y
viviremos con mayor bienestar
ese sería el segundo
una educación financiera adecuada para
lo largo de la vida
y el tercero el cuidado al final de la
vida
ese cuidado en donde seguramente nuestro
estado tendrá que establecer un sistema
nacional de cuidado que no existe
pero yo quisiera que esos bebés
aprendieran desde muy temprana edad
y así lo trato de inculcar entre los
míos
que somos finitos
y nacimos para morir
y que la buena muerte existe
buena muerte existe
como existe la realidad de nuestra
finitud
yo quisiera morir en ese escenario de
una buena muerte que la considero estar
rodeado de los míos
rodeado de mi esposa y mis hijos y los
seres que quiero
poderles decir que los amo
poderme despedir
y pedir perdón
y perdonar
pero sobre todo dar las gracias
agradecer el haber compartido
esta buena vida
la medida en que tengamos eso claro la
vida será mucho más
tranquila
es como cuando uno sale de viaje y sabe
el destino y acepta el destino
no anda preguntando a cada rato ya vamos
a llegar
y vamos a llegar
en el hospital la bata blanca
y el fonendoscopio está la enfermedad
y es importante que esa organización de
servicios de salud exista
exista bien y eficiente
pero debemos avanzar hacia una cultura
de la salud
a entender que la salud es ese bien
preciado
la salud es de todos nosotros
por eso hay que desmedicalizar la salud
o alguien bien dijo
la medicina es de los médicos
y la salud nos pertenece a todos
por eso yo los invito a qué
nos dejen la medicina a los médicos
y apropien monos todos de la salud ojalá
en una gran epidemia de salud de lo que
genera verdaderamente salud y poder les
enseñará esos hijos a de sus nietos a
esos sobrinos nietos que esa es la salud
y que esa es la prioridad mayor que
deben tener seguramente podrán vivir con
mayor bienestar
con mayor gratitud muchas gracias
[Aplausos]